so let's talk a little bit about debt
debt is just the amount of money that
you owe used in the form of loans it
could also be your balance on a credit
card which is really a loan from the
credit card issuer and I would say there
is good debt and there is bad debt good
debt is when you borrow money in order
to make an investment of some kind that
should produce more money than the
amount that you are borrowing and enough
money to actually even offset the
interest that you're going to have to
pay on that debt examples of things that
might be good debt is if you are
borrowing money to say buy a house
because that will reduce your rent
expense in the future and the house
itself might appreciate maybe you need
Transportation you need a car or a
motorcycle to get to your job or you
could get to a better job if you had
that you could work more hours because
you're going to spend less time getting
there that could be an investment it
could be you're going to invest in
yourself it could say hey I could take a
course or I could get a degree and yes
it's going to cost money then I'm going
to have to pay interest on on top of the
money I owe but it'll increase my my
actual job prospects and my income
enough that will more than offset that
money that I have to pay in the future
and even in those three scenarios three
or four scenarios be very very careful
if you're taking on student debt really
talk to people make sure that the degree
program you're getting into that line of
work that you're getting into that the
folks who decided to take debt on to do
that that it actually did pay off if you
buy a car make sure that it's something
that really is an investment and not
just something fancy that you want to
show off to your friends because at some
point yes it is transportation but if
you're starting to buy a very fancy car
and you're borrowing money to do it well
that the fanciness of the car isn't
going to necessarily increase your
ability to get to work or to get a
better job and then you're essentially
taking on debt for a want as opposed to
a need or an investment same thing with
buying a house it's not always the right
decision oftentimes it can be but really
weigh what you think is going to happen
how much rent you're going to save how
much the house might appreciate and
sometimes they don't they go down in
value too relative to how much you owe
and make sure that it's something that
you will be able to pay back over time
even if some bad things happen in life
you lose a job you have to spend money
on an emergency in some way shape or
form now on the other hand there's
things that I would categorize as bad
debt and this is when you are borrowing
money for things that frankly you do not
need because when you do that uh you're
you're essentially taking money away
from your future self and if you didn't
have money today to buy it and if you're
gonna have to pay that money back in the
future with interest you're taking
you're putting your future self in a
more and more difficult situation so I
would say a very obvious category of
this is let's say there's a big fancy
outfit you want to buy one that will not
help you get a job and you're like well
I don't have the money but it looks
really cool let me buy that well it
might feel good now but you're going to
be paying that down for a very very very
long time or using debt to go eat at a
fancy restaurant if you're using money
that you don't have once again it might
be fun in the moment but you're going to
be paying that down and taking away from
your future self and it can lead to from
pretty sub-optimal or not so great
situations there are folks that if they
start doing that they they take money
from their future self they see that
their income after they have to pay down
the debt and the interest in the
payments month after month their income
starts going lower and lower and lower
and lower that's a scary situation to be
in that will create a lot of stress and
create a lot of anxiety if you find
yourself in a situation where you're
borrowing to pay off other debt that can
also be a very big red flag create a lot
of stress and a lot of anxiety if on
things like your credit cards you're
just paying the minimum amount but the
balances aren't coming down and you're
usually paying very high interest on
those credit cards that is a very bad
situation that is setting you up for
um not not good Financial outcomes and
maybe worst of all when whenever someone
falls into one of these Cycles they
might just say oh I just want to look at
it it just stresses me out and then you
don't you're not even in a position
where you're paying your debt or you're
trying to ignore it and then that's
going to hit your credit rating and
eventually the collections folks are
going to come after you and that is a
very very bad situation maybe you have
to declare bankruptcy at some point in
the future so that can be useful but be
very very very careful with it